all right
there we are up to number 10 but we're
going to focus
on 12 initially that's the first guy we
haven't spoken about on that list that
you see ryan tannehill the 2019
comeback player of the year and now
number 12 on the chris sims top 40
quarterback countdown as shereen
williams said in 2019 when he was the
comeback player of the year what is he
coming back from
sucking that was her quote not mine and
she's a staunch texas
a m supporter in tannehill played
receiver at a
m before becoming a quarterback uh i
think for a year
at a m and then becoming the eighth
overall pick in the draft i i've always
been a ryan tannehill fan
it never worked out for him in miami the
planet's never quite aligned
and then he goes to tennessee and
everything falls into place and here he
is entering the second year
of a contract that frankly is better
than patrick mahomes
better than desean watson's and he's on
a team that was on the cusp of the super
bowl just two years ago chris and you've
got him at number 12.
why do you regard him as being in that
sort of echelon yeah well well i mean
first off you know
the the thing we got to do is get over
the 2017-2018 narrative that's the first
thing like
no it's 2021 shut the hell up and ryan
tannehill's good
right get over your old narrative it's
over he's proven it wrong and it was
better in miami than people ever wanted
to give it credit for
as we've talked about a lot anyways but
the thing about ryan tannehill that i
think is amazing
and this is one of my quotes on my
recent podcast
and i had a uh one of my homies at dr
babies there
you know he wrote it because i said this
like you know move the f
on stop holding oh it's ryan cannon hill
because this was all coming out wait
julio said he wanted to go to somewhere
where they had a top
top end quarterback and a big arm yeah
ryan tannehill is a top end quarterback
with a big arm
maximizes more down the field throws
than maybe just about anybody in
football
that's the that's the thing people got
to get over ryan tannehill
the degree of difficulty and the throws
he's asked to make
are high he makes them all the time with
ease
and doesn't leave yards on the field
like we talk about so much mike
i mean he's a good athlete it's seven
rushing touchdowns
he controls the football he's clutch
yards per completion are as good as
anybody in football
and you know they're going to throw the
ball down the field and he still throws
it down there with great success
so that's where he's really damn good
he's tough he's able to play in the
pocket we know we can scramble and run
and do those things
he's really played phenomenal football
the last two years and yes
for hands down for me is is one of the
12 best quarterbacks in football
it felt weird putting him at 12.
honestly mike i think his play
you know in a lot of ways you could
justify maybe being higher than that but
there's some damn good quarterbacks in
football right now
is it just me or does he look larger
with the titans than he ever did with
the dolphins
does that make sense it does bigger yeah
uniforms can do that and i do think it
looks like he's
thickened out a little bit like a little
he definitely got bigger legs than he
did in that miami dolphins uniform and
those type of things
but hey you know he really fits how they
want to play you know
run the ball okay scare you to death
with the run game creep
up to the line of scrimmage hey we're
going to make you defend the whole field
because we're going to throw 70-yard
bombs over the top of your head to corey
davis or
aj brown now aj brown and julio jones so
that's where he's really good
we know he has the threat of helping out
the run game because he can keep it
around the edge on the read option and
run for 30 yards down the sideline
and do while that really has played the
game
from a mental physical standpoint pretty
top-notch mike if there was one
complaint i would go he's
a great athlete you mentioned he's an
ex-receiver i think he could scramble
and make more plays in the back end
you know then more than he gives him
credit for but but everything else is
is pretty top-notch and he's got to be
happy with his play the last two years
derek henry has had his best two seasons
with ryan tannehill as the quarterback
now now
he's had a lot more touches the last two
years as well he went from 215
in 2018 to 303 rushing attempts
in 2019 and all the way to 378 last year
as he became the latest 2000 yard rusher
how much though does tana hill's
presence
give rise to what we've seen from henry
does it happen for henry without tanah
i don't think so they need some type of
quarterback like a tannehill in there
for henry to have
you know these last two years that we've
seen
you know because really hey in 2018 you
talk about those stats and him not
getting as many carries and those type
of things either
hey well the quarterback play dictated
that nobody was scared
of the quarterback everybody's at the
line of scrimmage so oh first down we
ran for nothing
oh second down we ran for nothing okay
now third down we gotta throw hey next
time we come out we now we're punting
next time we come out we can't run the
ball we gotta try to back these guys off
we can't do it so there goes two or
three carries maybe more that
derek henry doesn't get so yes i do
believe
ryan tannehill has directly affected
uh derek henry and his success we know
derek henry's the man no matter who
plays quarterback
but tannehill opens the field up and
he opens the field up to the point where
yeah if you do want to put those extra
guys in the box
you're you're taking a big chance
one-on-one down the field with these
guys because tannehill is not afraid to
to pull the trigger on deep throws and
and he's usually on the money
okay a fair question raised by
by where is it yeah boy l ray
should there be any worry of ryan
tannehill having a drop off
with the departure of arthur smith
former offensive coordinator
now the head coach of the falcons todd
downing takes over
as the offensive coordinator of the
tennessee titans yeah
yes a little bit i mean how can you deny
that but
todd downing i think you know smart
enough and and planning for mike frable
that
i don't think the formula on offense is
going to change a whole lot
it's still going to be a running the
ball play action pass
do that type of stuff and work it you
know where so i'm not necessarily
as concerned with that i do guess i get
a little concerned with
the dominance of the offensive line of
the titans to a degree
can they continue to dominate the way
they have the last few years
you know taylor lewand coming back from
injury you know the first round pick and
isaiah win
didn't come through you know they've had
to kind of put it patchwork together
this offensive line a little bit here
but i i don't think it's going to be a
lot of or much of a different look from
the offense
and maybe the run game isn't quite
what we've seen the last two years but i
would expect this is where julio jones
comes into play
to kind of make up the difference for
that and i
i still would expect this to be one of
the more dangerous offenses in football
this year
downing has uh on his resume work with
derek carr
as the offensive coordinator for raiders
back when carr was an mvp
candidate so that is a featherless cap
and once downing lost the job with the
raiders it kind of
kind of bottomed out for him he's been
working his way back right but here he
is taking over for arthur smith
after smith leaves if any time it
changes anytime it's different
that raises a question as to the
continuity sure consistency can the
quarterback continue to develop can this
coach get
the most out of that player yeah yeah
you're right meg
has been sorry sorry mike sorry go ahead
i was just saying but you're right their
number they were the number two offense
in football last year
you know pete i don't know if everybody
realizes that sometimes the tennessee
titans were number two
in football behind the kansas city
chiefs with yards per game
so yeah the pressure is on there's no
doubt you're right there's a spotlight
and if they fall too far todd downing
will be the guy that gets blamed
and and the presence of julio jones
ramps up that definitely
for everybody it increases expectations
for everybody and uh
you've got a new personality you've got
to get properly
meshed with the rest of the team you
have to hope it works and everyone's
assuming it's going to be fantastic you
have nowhere to go but
down i can understand why you know we
haven't heard a lot from mike verwell
about julio jones i can understand why i
think maybe he's trying to
let's take this slow sure i mean but we
can't just assume all of a sudden
we're going to be the 99 rams this year
uh and everyone is expecting an
explosion from the titans now that
they've gone out and gotten julio jones
all right let's move on to a team that
some are expecting an explosion from by
virtue of the fact that they have a
great young quarterback sixth overall
pick
in 2020 justin herbert all those
questions about herbert my gosh in
hindsight
i don't know maybe you could argue he
should have been the second overall pick
in the draft it's not the first overall
pick in the draft justin herbert coming
in at number 11
the offensive rookie of the year it
would have been joe burrow but for the
torn acl
herbert wins it uh in a runaway he got
thrust into the lineup
after dr needle had his encounter with
tyrod taylor
and he had five minutes notice for his
first nfl start and he started great
and he only got better as the year went
off he did and listen
i don't know do you think it would have
been burro i mean i i don't know
herbert was i think it would have been
burrow i think it would have been bro
because burroughs set the narrative
early yeah i got you and if burrell
would have kept playing like he had i
think it would have been
yeah the bangles and everything like
that it had been interesting to see it
certainly would have i mean because
burro yeah made some wow plays we know
that he's right
if he doesn't hurt his knee he's right
here in this conversation around 12
11 10 9 whatever somewhere in there but
herbert i think when you start the
conversation
is like like holy cow
holy arm batman i mean yeah yeah you
know
he he's one of the top five throwers of
the football in the whole nfl i think
already there's no doubt
arm is wow strong i mean you know
unreal size can throw the ball any which
way in the pocket
you know the one thing when i went back
and watched film mic and break them down
just
how many throws like off the back foot
with pressure around him or the pocket
collapsing
and he's just unaffected and still
throwing a 20-yard laser down the middle
of the field
you know to keenan allen or somebody
like that that's where it's really
impressive
and he's got great composure you know
but also with the size and the arm we're
talking about it's a guy who can
really like run too and whether it was
get outside the pocket
make throws on the run that way whatever
it may be he can do it all
physically and you saw mentally he was
capable of handling everything with it
so the sky's the limit this guy's got
superstar talent
and he's a big time football player and
he's going to be around for a long time
yeah hey look i agree with you
completely and uh the chargers now have
to build the team around him
to fulfill his promise and allow him to
get to his ceiling and and
and you know this is a team that's been
to a super bowl right one super bowl
94 super bowl 29 uh they've had teams
that were super bowl worthy
they've uh they've had maybe a team
that's going to get mentioned coming up
here in our draft today that looked like
they were on track to a super bowl and
it all fell apart yeah they go from
philip rivers
to justin herbert not a bad
passing of the baton and now we just
have to see what they can do with it and
uh
uh you know look it it it stanks for
herbert to be stuck in the division with
patrick
holmes but as we look for the next
manning brady
maybe it's herbert mahomes since they're
going to play each other twice a year
every year i don't think that's crazy i
mean he has the type of talent to take
over football games and we saw moments
of him doing that last year
you know whether it was the first half
of that bucks game pressure all around
him he's throwing bombs up and down the
field
we saw what he did against the new
orleans saints they're trying to blitz
him like crazy
he keeps just making a guy miss throwing
doing stuff like that
to me mike that is the only
i want to see more of a presence from
his personality this year
right i mean we showed our ranking
already you know
this is where brady got the notch above
justin herbert at 10
as compared to 11. you know presence
leadership
knowing the game of when to take a
chance when to check it down
wait you know we're kind of getting our
butts
rolled here by the new england patriots
i need to start making some plays we're
down 14 nothing i got to just start
doing it and push the limit a little bit
get us back in the game
that to me is the next phase for justin
herbert you know when you break him down
everything else is really good
it's just now a gal going exerting
yourself you know being a leader
having more of a presence on the
football field and knowing when that
moment is to go
okay i have to play maybe a little
reckless now because we're not playing
good today
and i got to put the team on my back and
make some plays happen
and if he does that he'll be up there
and you know mahomes and rogersville
before you know it
and when you are so highly regarded when
you win the offensive rookie of the year
if you stay healthy you do keep
ascending you do have that aura about
you even if you don't have to
try to do it you that they're going to
listen to you uh and and look the
personality type has a lot to do with
with what kind of a leader
a franchise quarterback is going to be
and how much he does set the tone
and and i agree with you that's an
important part of the skill set and we
don't know yet because it is so early
for him and then look in his defense
he played most of his rookie season tom
brady was third on the depth chart and
never played so
herbert's ahead of the curve he's got a
head start over brady
he's got a head start over my homes he
played
a lot in his rookie year he was the
offensive rookie of the year and we'll
see where he takes it
from here let's go ahead and take a
break speaking of brady
you noticed on the graphic at the start
of the segment tom brady at number 10.
plenty of people are upset about tom
brady at number 10
and chris has explained himself in other
formats on other shows he gets his
opportunity
to go under the hot light of my
interrogation because i'm coming at him
baby
why do you have tom brady at number 10.
why are you jealous
jealousy that's it he's all it's jealous
he's alive it's jealous i have a crap
i want his life that's crap i want his
life
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports